bringing back with the fox news alert we
can confirm now that a police officer
has in fact been
shot in the riots in louisville
should be disgusting demonstrations and
chaos have been going on in that city
since early this afternoon when a grand
jury reached a verdict in the brianna
taylor case matt finn
is in louisville for us right now and
joins us matt
tucker that shooting happened a distance
from us so we don't have any eyewitness
information to bring you but we're going
to keep you updated on that louisville
police officer apparently shot here
tonight in the city
happening right now police have declared
this area an unlawful assembly and over
the past
hour or so they've been coming on over
the loudspeaker warning people to clear
the area because
they started lighting fires some of
which you can still see they started
throwing objects at police
and police declared an unlawful assembly
and they
warned everyone to clear this area right
now it is much calmer than it was just a
short while ago we have officers
in their swat gear we have bearcats and
they are kind of going uh
back and forth between an ongoing
standoff with some protesters who are
coming up and screaming and yelling at
them but this is
a much calmer and less dangerous
situation than a short
while ago earlier in the day today there
was a large crowd here people chanting
profanities
against police people screaming in
officers faces throwing objects at them
so they ultimately established a little
bit of peace
here in this area right now tucker
yeah okay matt finn i appreciate it
thank you